TO KNOW WHAT IT IS WHEN IT'S
OPEN.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW TEXAS
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DAN PATRICK.
PEOPLE FROM VENEZUELA CROSSING
THE BORDER AND CONVICTED
MURDERERS AND CHILD MOLESTERS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAID WE
HAVE IT UNDER CONTROL.
>> IT'S UNEXPLAINABLE UNLESS YOU
ACCEPT THE PREMISE THEY KNOW
WHAT IS HAPPENING AND WANT IT TO
HAPPEN.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN
EXPLAIN IT.
THEY CAN'T BE THIS IGNORANT.
THEY SEE IT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
IT.
THINK ABOUT THIS A MOMENT:
60% OF THE PEOPLE COMING THROUGH
THE DEL RIO SEGMENT ARE COMING
FROM VENEZUELA.
THEY ARE FLYING FROM VENEZUELA
TO MEXICO CITY AND BUS IN.
WE HAVE A DIFFERENT SET OF
PEOPLE.
SOME ARE BETTER DRESSED.
THIS IS A MORE EDUCATED CLASS
FLEEING THEIR COUNTRY IN WITH
OTHER PEOPLE.
WE CAUGHT PEOPLE FROM SOUTH
AFRICA AND HAITI.
THEY ARE COMING FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
>> Laura: WHY WOULDN'T THEY?
THIS IS THE MOST RIDICULOUS
SITUATION.
WE ARE HEARING FROM PEOPLE IN
NEW ORLEANS, RAYMOND'S REPORT,
AND PEOPLE ON THE STREETS IN NEW
ORLEANS.
WHAT ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
NOT THAT WE DON'T HAVE FEELINGS
AND CONCERNED ABOUT EVERYBODY,
BUT WE HAVE AN AMERICAN PROBLEM
RIGHT NOW WITH WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH THIS RIDICULOUS, PROLONGED
RESPOND TO THE PANDEMIC AND
LOCKING KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL.
NOW ALL OF HUMANITY WILL SHOW UP
AND WALK RIGHT IN.
>> LAURA, WE ARE ONLY 3 WEEKS
FROM THE END OF SESSION.
WE HAD A MEETING TODAY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
WE ARE GOING TO PUT IN
SIGNIFICANT MORE MONEY TONIGHT.
WE WILL PUT IN SIGNIFICANT MORE
MONEY INTO OUR BORDER SECURITY.
WE ALREADY SPEND CLOSE TO $400
MILLION A YEAR ON TAX DOLLARS TO
PROTECT TEXAS AND PROTECT
AMERICA FROM THE CRIMINALS
COMING IN.
WE WILL ADD TO THAT AND HAVE
MORE PERSONNEL AND MORE ASSETS
ON THE BORDER AND DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN IN TEXAS.
THE BORDER PATROL THEY ARE
DEMORALIZED.
THEY ARE TAKING CARE OF FAMILIES
AND KIDS.
THE SHERIFF IS OVERRUN.
THE JAILS ARE OVERRUN.
IT'S A DISASTER.
>> Laura: I WAS IN DEL RIO IN
MAY OF 2019 AND WE THOUGHT IT
WAS BAD THEN.
IT WAS RIGHT BEFORE THEY
INSTITUTED THE RETURN TO MEXICO
POLICY.
IT WAS BAD THEN.
>> BIDEN COULD OVERTURN THIS
AGAIN OVERNIGHT WITH THAT MEXICO
POLICY THAT TRUMP CREATED.
>> Laura: THIS ENRICHED THE
CARTELS.
ONE WORD FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE?
>> IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
YOU ARE ALLOWING PEOPLE TO BE
ENSLAVED.
YOU ARE CREATIN